la danza e connessione
connessioni di piedi gambe ginocchia
anche bacino braccio testa e cuore
è un'energia che dalle dita dei piedi
fino alla punta del più lungo dei nostri
capelli connette ogni parte del nostro
corpo ogni fibra dei nostri muscoli ogni
articolazione che tiene insieme le
nostre ossa quando danziamo è come se
ogni cellula del nostro corpo si
muovesse e con essa anche ogni strato
della nostra anima
la danza permetta al corpo di muoversi
nello spazio e oltre lo spazio
connettendo le nostre emozioni a quelle
di chi balla con noi ma anche di chi ci
guarda di chi si sente
la danza infatti e ascolto prima ancora
di essere movimento ascolto del nostro
corpo che si muove nello spazio della
musica che con tra i nostri muscoli
dell'area che spostiamo attraverso i
movimenti ascolto dello spazio che ci
sta intorno e delle persone che con noi
lo condividono la danza è uno dei primi
modi con cui l'uomo ha imparato ad
esprimersi pensate i bambini fin da
piccolissimi quando centro una canzone
la seconda non ritmo con movimenti buffi
e ripetuti quella e danza anzi forse
nell espressione più pura
la danza è nata milioni di anni fa io
l'ho conosciuta solo a 5 anni ma lei pur
rimanendo sempre la stessa ha cambiato
per sempre ogni parte di me e di mia
sorella unendoci e creando nuove
connessioni tra noi e con il mondo
è la nascita ho avuto un'astuzia
militare che ma cos'ha detto
il plastico se cosa dei servizi e dei
molti e miss piante viso bambino dopo i
18 anni erano praticamente
non mi fermo e buzduca alza dalla sedia
a rotelle e 6 massa è sempre un vegetale
il mio dio sembra sveglio alcol già
depistanti higuita
eppure nonostante da parte dei medici e
le difficoltà oggi sono qui ho 29 anni e
sono buttato gumi gita e ho tagliato
numerosità guai che mi chiamo amica sono
laureata opportuno scuoia vigenza
insieme a mia sorella
sto coltivando
molti sogni e obiettivi
alcuni 10 nov
anche
realizzati
il mio percorso di vita
di crescita e di
scoperta e gli credo in un momento
specifico
che è finito un un velo alta
più.ne
con la mia vita precedente e soprattutto
con gli amici che mi erano stati imposti
è successo un dolo commediante ogni
tanto tempo fa lo sconto
è uscita con mentito per compagnie
pasqua
vedendo che i bombi in guardai mi sono
sentito prima
nè di dio particolare da una furia e da
un entusiasmo in tempi che
successivamente
adesso e alle
imprese
e sei in grado di
così con trono
nettamente in con funky come mi sono
alzata in piedi appunto anno mi auguro
provando imitare i passi che vedevo
eseguita o completo anch'io segue
bellissimi anche che dopo un po
facoltà di
mente
dopotutto
un sollievo e nessuno aveva mai pensato
che potessi nome o combinare
figuriamoci guardare
ma non opec anti sismici nome e mi aiuto
a danzare
sostenendomi con il suo e beta e
guidandomi con i suoi piedi
permettendomi tramite il suo corpo io li
vedo
io ancora bloccato grazie a lei ho
scontato la mia volta quel senso di
comunione con l'altro di sostegno
l'equipe di
condivisione che provocato di biglietti
insieme e non un permesso perché a
destra è diventata il mio modo di
connette mia mente è il mio corpo e allo
stesso tempo me stessa con gli alti
la danza mi ha permesso di avere una
percezione inedita del mio corpo una
consapevolezza che va oltre alla
coreografia e oltre il mio singolo
involucro esterno
limitato nello spazio e nel tempo perché
mi ha permesso di creare delle
connessioni dei movimenti e delle
esperienze connessioni che mi hanno
legato a me stessa in tutte le mie
componenti a mia sorella e infine al
resto del mondo
un legame indissolubile tra gambe e
cuore capace di far tremare i pavimenti
ma soprattutto le anime la danza mi ha
insegnato che le mie gambe sono solo
protuberanze prive di vita senza la
guida della testa che le braccia non
sono che rami mossi dal vento
se non sono controllate dal cuore che
ogni piccola parte di me anche quella
più insignificante conta e conta perché
senza di lei tutte le altre sarebbero
orfane e orfana sarebbe anche la mia
danza
pensate alla milza forse solo i medici e
pochi altri sanno di preciso dove si sa
a cosa serva ma è la prima cosa a farci
male quando corriamo e in quel momento
solo in quel momento ci ricordiamo di
lei che poi quando si pensa alla corsa
si pensa ai muscoli ai polmoni al cuore
mica la milza
eppure lei esiste e si fa sentire
lo stesso avviene per la danza la danza
non è solo gambe lunghe capaci di
toccare il cielo e piroette senza fine
ma nasce dall'unione delle parti del
nostro corpo in una rete profondamente e
inevitabilmente connesso ma questa rete
non si ferma semplicemente alcun fine
delimitato dal corpo e nemmeno alla
mente
è una rete
potenzialmente infinita i corpi e menti
di barili che sarà apple sul palco
portano non solo il loro corpo ma
l'espressione degli occhi
sono davvero
l'ecologia non si compone di pezzi ma
gli propone
così come un gioco non si confonde gli
uccelli ma anche un pubblico gli occhi
chi colgono menti che è a mano fuori che
sento
sia con gli scogli minuti
nei volti anonimi corpo e mente una rete
infinita di corpi e menti di baby le
difese ma anche insieme san luca e la
corsia più quella del mondo in tempo
cosa farà di danza intimi al top in caso
in realtà non esiste anzi e rizzi nella
formando una rete più quindi un salto
nel buio
quella rete oggi il mio corpo la mia
scuola e persone che con me mi vorrai
perché è uno solo emozione ma tendenza
ad uno di passion e commuove
quindi non lasciatevi bloccare dall'idea
di non potere
insieme balliamo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
e lui
poi me
ne
[Musica]
importa niente che non perdona
massimo scura mi
un capriccio
[Musica]
ce l'ha
niente male
io che non respirava e pinar della nava
[Musica]
missino scuola
dopo un capriccio
che sfugge
[Musica]
paura
si no
[Musica]
non mi ha scocciato
capri
[Musica]
è scusato
acqua
la prossima
porteremo incontra nella galassia mio
cena in aria a stucchi settantina mia
moglie siamo ancora bambino
[Musica]